What superstitions do you have?
Because my family is Korean
and my mom grew up in Korea and has
a ton of really crazy superstitions, like,
"You can't whistle at night
because snakes will come."
"You shouldn't like clip your
fingernails before an exam,"
because it's like,
you're, you're getting rid
of your knowledge somehow,
like various kinds of
superstitious things.
So do you
have any superstitions?
Yeah,
you're saying it's cultural.
Well, Sona, you can relate to this because
Oh, millions!
Sona, she comes from this
real hardcore Armenian culture
and she wears those eyes.
What are they called?
They're the "evil eye."
I have them everywhere.
But what are they called?
Yeah yeah yeah.
They're called the "evil eye."
Oh, I thought they had an Armenian name.
"Achk."
So she has an achk
and she has them everywhere.
She has them in her car,
She has them hanging around,
you know, it's the first thing you see
when you walk through
the door of her house.
She wears them on her body.
I mean, it looks like she's,
Hm, yeah I do.
Really, it looks like you're
an ophthalmologist or something.
Yeah, I feel like you mooch
off of my superstition.
No, I've sometimes asked you,
when I've needed something or
I need somebody to go well,
I've asked your mom to use her achk
to try and help me out.
Yeah. Right.
You know?
There's a lot of
superstitions we use, yeah.
And we protect you when
you don't even realize it.
Well, I come from
absolutely batshit crazy,
(laughter)
inbred Irish people.
And I swear to God, our grandmother,
our grandmother, who
I think she was,
when she was living with us,
I think she was 97.
Wow!
And she lived in the house
with us.
There were six of us kids
and my mother and my dad and
dogs and cats and parakeets.
And it was just a madhouse.
And she used to say all these things,
like I remembered her telling me,
"Don't sit down on wet grass
or you'll get diarrhea."
(laughter)
Wow!
"Don't sit down on wet grass..."
Now that sounds less like a superstition
than she thought that was real sound
medical advice.
Sounds like something
she's telling you out
of experience, you know.
Well I don't know, that's what she said.
She said, "Don't sit down on
wet grass...you have diarrhea."
And, and there was this
woman, I won't name her
but she worked with,
she helped out and she
helped take care of us
'cause my parents were off working.
And I remembered my brother, Luke,
he got a wart on his hand.
Mhm.
And so she said, "I'll fix that."
And she cut a potato in half,
rubbed one half of the potato on the wart
and buried the other half in the backyard.
(laughing)
Of course, it's a potato.
(Sona laughs)
Yes, yes and you know what?
There were plenty of potatoes around.
Well, did it work?
So I grew up
and then the weird thing is, as you said
my dad's a microbiologist
or so he says.
But he'd be like "Hmm,
yes, that sound good to me,
off to the bus station to
pretend I'm a microbiologist."
(Sona laughs)
So yeah, the whole thing,
was a shit show.
Uh huh
And I think that superstitious brain
has come with me
and I'm not kidding. I think
my biggest superstition,
I'm not proud of this, is
I think I have to be kind of unhappy
for something to go well.
Hm
And that's really true.
You've probably noticed that, Sona, like
if I have a show to do,
if I'm feeling too good beforehand
Mhm.
and I think I do this,
this is not a joke.
I think I like to go to a dark place
before I allow myself to
go out into a happy place.
That gives me...
And that is not a, I've
had cognitive therapy.
I know that that is, it
doesn't make any sense.
But that probably, for real,
is my real superstition
and one that has been
a huge pain in the ass in my life.
Oh. It's the Irish-Catholic, right?
It's the Irish-Catholic,
you know, it's just this,
"You got to feel bad to feel good."